danke schön
ja hallo und herzlich willkommen zum
kanzlergespräch in Marburg mein Name ist
Evren Gezer ich begrüße natürlich alle
zuschauenden in den verschiedenen
Livestreams ein ganz herzliches Hallo an
unsere Gäste hier im Lokschuppen in
Marburg schön dass Sie da sind und last
but not least natürlich möchte ich sie
hier Bundeskanzler ganz herzlich bei uns
in Hessen willkommen heißen schön dass
Sie bei uns sind hallo
sie werden im Rahmen der
kanzlergespräche überall mal halt machen
in jedem Bundesland gewesen sein um mit
den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern auch
wirklich mal ganz direkt ins Gespräch zu
kommen um aus nächster Nähe mal
nachzuhorchen was die Menschen
beschäftigt womit Sie zufrieden sind
womit sie vielleicht auch nicht ganz so
zufrieden sind den Auftakt gab es
letztes Jahr im Sommer in Lübeck
anschließend waren sie in Magdeburg in
Essen in Gifhorn und jetzt eben zum
fünften kanzlergespräch hier bei uns im
hessischen Marburg und ja das sind die
150 Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer die
sich auf den Aufruf der Oberhessischen
Presse gemeldet haben und aus über 600
interessierten ausgelost worden sind und
sich auf die nächsten 90 Minuten mit ihm
freuen vielleicht möchten Sie auch noch
mal so ganz persönlich hallo sagen guten
Abend ich freue mich auf das Gespräch
ich hoffe es geht kreuz und quer über
alle Themen und für mich ist das ganz
toll und wichtig weil es gibt keine
bessere Erdung über das was wirklich los
ist im Land als solche Gespräche zu
führen und deshalb gucken wir mal das
wird schon netter Abend absolut ganz
ganz sicher wir kommen sofort zu den
Fragen einer einleitende vielleicht noch
denn sie sind ja nicht eben erst
angereist in Marburg sie waren schon
unterwegs heute beim biontech-standort
hier in Marburg und das finde ich
persönlich sehr interessant anschließend
waren sie bei einer Sitzung des Kinder-
und Jugendparlaments
vielleicht ein kurzer Eindruck dazu
welche welche ja Wünsche sie da
mitbekommen haben was bewegt die jungen
Menschen und hat man vielleicht auch
ganz konkrete Wünsche an sie geäußert
die sie jetzt mit auf den Weg nehmen das
war ganz toll
großartige Kinder und Jugendliche alle
zusammen und das ist ja dann doch schon
ein ganz großes Altersspektrum aber es
war ein unglaubliches Interesse zu
spüren an dem was los ist ich fand schon
bemerkenswert das auch von den ganz
kleinen einige Fragen zu dem Krieg
gestellt haben und auch sehr besorgt
sind über die Auswirkungen die das hat
mich welche was zur Rente gefragt ist
also auch das ist vorgekommen und
vielleicht von Mama und Papa Bauch haben
dann auch diskutiert über
Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten von Kindern
und Jugendlichen und wie man die
Möglichkeiten verbessern kann ein
Ausbildungsplatz zu kriegen was man tun
soll studieren Ausbildung was ist besser
es ging es war wirklich lebendig
wunderbar das hoffe ich auch das ist
heute Abend wird dann begebe ich mich
mal hier auf meine Position und schaue
schon direkt in die Runde da gab es
schon einige eifrige Meldungen und gucke
dann mal hier und würde sagen dass
vielleicht der Herr hier vorne mit der
Brille am Stehtisch gerne mal beginnen
darf hallo ja guten Tag Herr Scholz mein
Name ist Heinrich Hahn ich komme aus dem
wunderschönen Bioenergiedorf oberroste
und ich habe eine frage zum Klimaschutz
ich habe letzte Woche eine Studie
gelesen der Deutschen Umwelthilfe wonach
30 % der verkehrsklima erziele 2030
erreicht würden wenn Tempolimit 100
eingeführt wurde konkrete Frage das
spricht dagegen dass sie das Einführen
also zunächst mal mit meinem
Wahlprogramm der Partei der ich
angerührt stand auch ein Vorschlag nicht
bei 100 sondern bei 130 aber um die
Antwort kurz und knapp zu machen dafür
gibt es keine gesetzgebungsmehrheit das
hat sich bei der Regierungsbildung nicht
ergeben dass das ein Vorhaben der von
mir geführten Regierung wird aber wir
werden alles dafür tun dass auch der
Verkehr die Mobilität ihren Beitrag zum
Klimaschutz leistet und ein ganz
wichtiger Weg ist ja dass wir die größte
Modernisierung der individuellen
Mobilität vornehmen die seit Beginn der
automobilzeit jetzt möglich wird nämlich
mit der Elektrifizierung des Verkehrs
die deutschen Unternehmen sind alle
dabei das möglich zu machen wir wollen
die Lade Infrastruktur bauen gerade
klappt das auch entgegen aller
Vorhersagen mit dem Fortschritt bei dem
Lastwagen und wir werden zum Beispiel
jetzt mit der
CO2 betonten
Lkw-Maut die letzte gibt es ja schon ab
nächsten Jahr dazu beitragen dass auch
ganz viele auf solche
emissionsreduzierten Fahrzeuge setzen im
Lkw-Verkehr das wird auch dramatisch die
Emissionen reduzieren
danke dann habe ich vorhin eine Meldung
gesehen ganz vorne genau die Dame mit
dem gemusterten mit der zweiten Reihe
mit der Brille
guten Abend ich finde es wunderbar dass
die Kinder und Jugendparlament waren
mein Name ist Professor Katja Becker ich
bin Direktorin der Klinik für Kinder und
Jugendpsychiatrie am Uniklinikum Marburg
und im Koalitionsvertrag steht schon
drin und wann werden wir die
Kinderrechte im Artikel 2 Grundgesetz
haben
schöne Frage vor allem die Kinder haben
mich das auch gefragt und deshalb ist
das ja ein großes Anliegen ich wünschte
mir dass das längst der Fall wäre ich
habe das auch in der letzten
Legislaturperiode schon versucht es ist
nicht gelungen eine gemeinsame
Textfassung mit man damaligen
Koalitionspartner von der cdu/csu zu
schaffen die auch mehrheitsfähig
geworden wäre und jetzt ist es so dass
die Regierung will alle drei Parteien
finden das richtig die jetzt die
Regierung tragen aber weil es eine
Verfassungsänderung ist müssen wir die
größte Oppositionspartei irgendwie davon
überzeugen dass sie mitmacht sonst
gibt's keine zwei Drittel Mehrheit im
Bundestag und die braucht man für eine
Grundgesetzänderung
wo haben wir noch fragen vielleicht die
Dame hier vorne mit dem schwarzen Sakko
und dem roten Shirt da kommt gleich ein
Mikrofon kleinen Moment
schönen guten Abend danke erstmal dass
Sie Interesse haben an unseren Anliegen
mein Name ist Johanna Liebmann ich bin
Hausärztin seit 13 Jahren und ich habe
mit ganz viel Euphorie gestartet und
mittlerweile muss ich sagen gucke ich
mit viel Frustration auf Entwicklung im
Gesundheitssystem
wir versuchen hier in Marburg schon
durch die prima Prävention in Marburg
ein Ärzten jetzt aufzubauen was einfach
unsere Patienten optimal uns versorgen
lässt und wir haben auch in der Pandemie
gezeigt was wir für dieses System
leisten wollen und können und ich war
immer stolz Teil dieses System sein zu
können
wann bekommen wir dafür die
Wertschätzung im niedergelassenen
Bereich wann werden wir weniger
Bürokratie haben im Sinne von
Digitalisierung die nicht ausgereift ist
uns aber aufgezwungen wird und wir
fragen uns auch wann werden wir auch die
finanziellen Unterstützung kriegen dafür
die uns hilft
Energiekrise Inflationen steigende
mitarbeiterpreise der hervorragende
Arbeit bei uns leisten aber viele Kosten
kommen und auf uns zu und gestern unser
Abrechnung gekriegt wir haben 10 bis 15%
Einbußen von Quartal 322 hatten aber 10%
mehr Patienten behandelt wir haben das
Gefühl wir werden nicht gesehen von der
Politik und würden uns sehr wünschen ja
da kann ich Ihnen aber versichern dass
sie sehr gesehen werden erstens bin ich
auch einfach nur ein normaler Mensch und
geht zum Arzt oder zu Ärztin ich habe
hervorragende niedergelassene Ärzte die
sich um mich kümmern und deshalb geht's
mir vielen vielen anderen wir sehen das
schon und das gilt auch für die Politik
klar wir haben jetzt viele
Schwierigkeiten gehabt auch durch die
lange 19 Pandemie und die Auswirkungen
die das hatte aber da sind ja durch die
Erhöhung unserer Staatsschulden
Milliarden reingepumpt worden um die
verschiedenen Bereiche unseres
Gesundheitssystems und der Pflege durch
die Zeit zu bringen wir haben viel Geld
sowohl im niedergelassenen Bereich als
auch in den Krankenhäusern als auch in
den Pflegeeinrichtungen investiert damit
das nicht kaputt geht in dieser Zeit und
damit die viele Arbeit die dort
geleistet wird auch honoriert wird das
gilt insbesondere will ich das noch mal
sagen dafür die vielen Pflegekräfte in
den Krankenhäusern alte vielleicht
Altenpflegeeinrichtungen auch bei ihnen
in ihrer Praxis ihre Mitarbeiter und
Mitarbeiter und ich glaube das kann man
schon sagen das werden wir machen was
die Digitalisierung betrifft bin ich
der Meinung die ihre Frage
irgendwie offenbar ausdrückt aber bin
nicht ganz sicher ob wir uns ganz einig
sind also wir müssen digitalisieren und
wir müssen es viel besser machen als
bisher und wir müssen aber den
Machtkampf mit den Institutionen
gewinnen die in den letzten Jahren und
Jahrzehnten mit harten Interventionen
das von ihm jetzt Beklagte System
erstritten haben also es ist ja die sind
ja die Verbände gewesen die oft dafür
gekämpft haben dass man solche Systeme
hat viele haben für ganz sichere Systeme
gekämpft das ist jetzt mit technischen
Infrastrukturen laufen muss und jetzt
müssen wir das einfach mal machen aber
gleichzeitig müssen und das kann jetzt
nicht ich weiß nicht sind glaube ich 20
Jahre die dieses Land damit verbracht
hat digitale Patientenakte die digitales
Rezept und sonstige Dinge auf den Weg zu
bringen und natürlich wenn man vor 20
Jahren anfängt endet man mit einer
Technik die man politisch dann irgendwie
durchgesetzt hat die vielleicht in
dieser Zeit auch nicht mehr der
modernste Stand der Dinge ist daraus
jetzt aber zu schließen wir lassen das
alles und bleiben beim Papier das wäre
natürlich völlig falsch und deshalb
sagen wir wir führen das jetzt ein aber
wir sorgen gleichzeitig dafür dass die
großen modernisierungsschritte
stattfinden und es wäre ganz toll wenn
Sie mithelfen könnten dass alle dann
auch für die Modernisierung sind und uns
nicht zwei Bände an Einwänden gegen
jeden digitalisierungsschritt schicken
so läuft das nämlich normalerweise ab
und davon dürfen wir uns nicht mehr
abhalten lassen
ist Ihre Frage ausreicht beantwortet
halbwegs zufriedenstellend
das stimmt da könnte man lange drüber
sprechen vielen Dank
erst vielleicht ja okay dann würde ich
bitten dass wir den Herrn hier vorne
vielleicht noch mal das Mikro reichen
genau
kommt gleich jemand bleiben Sie ruhig
sitzen genau mein Name ist Wilhelm
Hermann ich habe als Angehöriger der
älteren Generation eine Frage an Sie
Herr Bundeskanzler die
ältere Gesellschaft betreffend gerade
die ältere Generation profitiert sehr
stark von den Fortschritten der
Digitalisierung
dass viele Lebensbereiche betreffend
auch das Gute altwerten auch für ein
gutes Zusammenleben von Alt- und jung
und für anderes mehr
aber nicht alle
Mitmenschen gerade auch nicht alle
ältere profitieren davon da die
digitalen Kompetenzen für viele Menschen
gerade für viele ältere nicht ausreichen
oder aber gar nicht vorhanden sind das
führt unter Umständen häufig zu sozialer
gesellschaftlicher Abgrenzung bis hin zu
einer pauschalen Diskriminierung
älterer Menschen deswegen meine Frage
und Bitte an Sie was tut die
Bundesregierung dafür dass für alle
Mitmenschen neben den
digitalen Möglichkeiten immer auch in
Zukunft
verpflichtend von Gesetzeswegen
herkömmliche
Zugangswege zu
öffentlichen und geschäftlichen
Einrichtungen verpflichtend vorgehalten
werden müssen
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage und im
übrigen haben sie da mit allem Recht was
Sie gesagt haben erstens das ist ja die
erste Botschaft ziemlich viele
ältere Leute kommen ganz gut zurecht
auch mit der Digitalisierung
meine Mutter schickt mir auch SMS und
das geschieht bei vielen anderen auch
insofern kann man klar sagen die
schaffen das schon aber nicht alle das
ist auch wahr und deshalb ist es wichtig
dass das Prinzip immer beachtet wird das
ist keine neuen Barrieren gibt sowieso
nicht für Menschen mit Behinderung bei
denen das ja auch eine Rolle spielen
kann gerade auch digitale Angebote
müssen so gemacht werden dass sie zum
Beispiel nicht Barriere
aufbauen aber es muss auch immer Wege
daneben geben wie man alle Leistungen
beantragen kann alle Unterstützung
bekommen kann und das gilt ganz
besonders auch für
ältere Menschen und insofern will ich
Ihnen nur sagen wir achten eigentlich
darauf dass niemand ausgeschlossen wird
dass wir niemals das unmöglich machen
dass jemand der keine digitalen
Möglichkeiten hat und damit auch nicht
so recht kommt nicht mehr weiß was er
oder sie tun soll und das wird noch
lange so sein und da glaube ich hat eine
Gesellschaft auch eine Verpflichtung das
möglich zu machen das können wir nicht
einfach allen vorschreiben
danke schön hier vorne am Stehtisch in
dem grünen farbenen Pullover
guten Tag mein Name ist Marine Diehl ich
möchte mit Ihnen gerne was persönliches
teilen meine Schwester hat mit 18 Jahren
sexualisierte Gewalt erfahren müssen und
da sie daraufhin schwere Depressionen
entwickelt hat haben wir über 50
Therapeutinnen in Köln angeschrieben wir
haben KV und den weißen Ring kontaktiert
und trotzdem hat sie erst zwei Jahre
danach ein Therapieplatz bekommen wo ich
mich jetzt Frage wir haben genug
Psychotherapeutin aber wir haben einfach
nicht genug kassensitze was möchten Sie
dafür tun dass es diese kassensitze gibt
und dass Menschen mit psychischen
Erkrankungen wie meiner Schwester
geholfen wird ja erstmal ähm das ist
ganz schick schrecklich und das gehört
ja unverändert zu dem zur Wirklichkeit
unserer Gesellschaft dazu dass es Gewalt
gibt gerade Gewalt gegen Frauen
sexualisierte Gewalt und das ist ein
Phänomen das jeden Tag sich hier wieder
zuträgt und ja auch im nächsten Bereich
immer wieder geschieht und ich finde für
unsere Gesellschaft ist ganz ganz
wichtig dass wir darüber nicht schweigen
dass das laut angesprochen wird und dass
wir auch alles dafür tun
diejenigen zu beschützen die solche
Gewalt von solcher Gewalt bedroht sind
aber auch alles tun dagegen dass das
überhaupt passiert
im übrigen aber haben sie völlig recht
das ist ein Thema das mich schon lange
begleitet und auch bei den Diskussionen
der letzten Jahre ist oft gesagt worden
wir haben nicht genügend Möglichkeiten
für Therapien für psychiatrische
Begleitung für alles das was nötig ist
einer schwierigen Lebenssituation und
deshalb haben wir uns als Regierung
vorgenommen das zu ändern indem wir da
auch Schritte einreichen wollen
ergreifen wollen die dazu führen dass es
mehr Angebote gibt heute als ich mit den
Kindern gesprochen habe gab es das Thema
auch nicht wegen sexualisierter Gewalt
aber wegen Kindern die zum Beispiel
durch in der corona-zeit Einsamkeit
gespürt haben die nicht mehr ganz
zurechtkommen und die auch Therapie und
Unterstützung brauchen und deshalb ist
das ein dringendes Anliegen dass wir die
Angebote ausweiten und ich bin gerne zu
sagen dass wir das uns nicht nur
vorgenommen haben sondern auch umsetzen
wollen
vielen Dank für die sehr konkrete Frage
hier vorne der Herr in der ersten Reihe
mit der Weste und dem karierten Hemd
das Mikro kommt
ja guten Tag mein Name ist Martin Gronau
ich bin hier im Wohnmobil in Marburg bin
im Ortsbeirat aber auch in der
frühdienstinitiative mit da können sich
wahrscheinlich auch vorstellen dass ein
bisschen meine Frage in diese Richtung
geht also
warum wir sie haben mal in einer
kürzlich gesagt dass die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger da Vertrauen könnten dass die
Bundesregierung sozusagen das
Verantwortung an die Hand nimmt das ist
Situationen da nicht eskaliert und meine
Frage ist wie weit können wir
tatsächlich vertrauen sie haben im
20.2 letzten Jahres gesagt es gäbe keine
Waffenlieferung in die Ukraine es wurden
Waffen in die Ukraine geliefert sie
haben am 2.11 gesagt es würden keine
Panzer in EU keine geliefert es wurden
jetzt Panzer oder stehen jetzt bevor das
Panzer geliefert werden jetzt haben sie
kürzlich am 25.01 diesen Jahres gesagt
dass keine Kampfflugzeuge und keine
Truppen der NATO Truppen geliefert
werden wie können wir darauf vertrauen
dass diese Eskalationsspirale nicht
immer weitergeht ich denke diese Sorge
treibt viele Menschen um das doch
irgendwann tatsächlich eben ein sagen
wir mal Stellvertreter kriegt den für
diesen viele da steht tatsächlich nichts
weiter eskaliert das ist im Grunde auch
ein bisschen meine Frage und andere
Frage vielleicht formulieren Sie genau
danke schön genau die Frage wie weit
können wir da
diesen Vertrauen doch gerecht werden
oder wie ist es dazu verstehen und
kleine Anschlussfrage wäre es nicht
eigentlich der bessere Weg zu sagen
diplomatie ist die Alternative das
Gespräch suchen es gab ja Angebote in
der Richtung auf Gesprächsbasis Krieg zu
beenden und nicht zu versuchen das immer
weiter sozusagen hochzutreiben ja
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage
und ich bin ehrlicherweise sehr froh
dass sie mir die Stellen auch für den
Beifall den sie bekommen haben für Ihre
Frage denn das ist ja das Tolle an so
einem Gespräch hier das geht ein
bisschen anders so zu als wenn ich jetzt
in Berlin im Fernsehen ein Interview
geben würde dann würde mir die Frage
fast nie gestellt also sie ist mir
natürlich nicht ein einziges Mal
gestellt worden wenn ich das so sagen
darf und deshalb ist es so dass es gut
ist dass sie es tun damit ich Ihnen eine
Antwort geben kann erstmal was wir hier
erleben ist ein russischer Angriffskrieg
auf die Ukraine das ist ein
imperialistischer Krieg russland will
Teile des Territoriums der Ukraine
erobern mit Gewalt
möglicherweise hatte Russland vor die
ganze Ukraine zu erobern und hatte auch
gehofft das geht einfach und schnell
so ist es nicht gekommen aber
ausdrücklich muss man sagen das können
wir nicht akzeptieren denn die
Friedensordnung die sicherheitsordnung
Europas das was Willy Brandt und Helmut
Schmidt erkämpft haben war die
Verständigung darüber dass es in Europa
keine gewaltsame Verschiebung von
Grenzen mehr gibt dass man nicht in
Geschichtsbüchern blättert wie jetzt
Putin und rausguckt wo war mal Russland
früher und zu sagen das will ich alles
wieder haben oder dass man irgendwie
guckt wer spricht so ähnlich und sagen
gehört auch in mein Land das sind ja
zwei Gründe die wenig
komplizierter real als Begründung für
seine jetzige Vorgehensweise beschreibt
und das geht nicht das können wir nicht
akzeptieren und deshalb ist es auch
richtig dass wir viele Dinge die wir in
Deutschland Jahrzehnte lang anders
gemacht haben jetzt anders machen darum
habe ich gesagt entscheide ich dass wir
die Ukraine mit Waffen unterstützen das
habe ich nach dem Kriegsausbruch erklärt
und dazu stehe ich aus und Deutschland
hat das mittlerweile sehr umfassend
getan auf dem europäischen Kontinent
sind wir mittlerweile diejenigen die das
am allermeisten tun das wirkt manchmal
anders wenn man das eine oder andere
liest oder hört oder sieht aber die
Wirklichkeit ist das schon und ich bin
in der Frage wie ich damit umgehe immer
sehr genau gewesen also ich habe
das was sie gerade behauptet haben eben
nicht getan gesagt das werden wir nicht
tun das werden wir nicht tun das wäre
nicht tun sondern ich habe das gemacht
woran ich mich die ganze Zeit auch
gehalten habe nämlich dass wir alle
unsere Schritte sorgfältig abwägen dass
wir nicht glauben dass es schon egal ist
was wir tun sondern genau überlegen wie
wir verhindern dass es zu einer
Eskalation des Krieges kommt dass das
kein Kind bleibt zwischen Russland als
Angreifer und der Ukraine die wir
unterstützen sondern zu einem Krieg wird
zwischen Russland und der NATO denn das
wäre furchtbar und darum habe ich und da
haben wir auch die Verantwortung alles
dafür zu tun dass diese Eskalation nicht
passiert und darum bekenne ich mich dazu
dass ich bewusst und mit Absicht und
ganz Konsequenz immer wieder gesagt hat
ist bleiben abgewogene Schritte und ich
mache keine allein Gänge und wenn einige
Leute laut rufen die voran oder sonst
was sage ich das ist nicht der richtige
Weg wir gehen mit anderen gemeinsam
insbesondere mit unserem amerikanischen
Verbündeten den USA und alle wichtigen
Schritte wo wir
wirksamere Waffen geliefert haben
Artillerie
Flakpanzer Luft Attraktor
Luftverteidigung
jetzt dass Iris t-system mit dem man die
vielen Raketenangriffe abwehren kann
die patreten mit dem man das auch
erreichen kann die Möglichkeit dass wir
Schützenpanzer liefern und zuletzt jetzt
die Kampfpanzer habe ich immer
entschieden mit anderen zusammen wir
sind nicht ein einzigen dieser Schritte
alleine gegangen und ich sage
ausdrücklich das werde ich auch nicht
tun das ist unverantwortlich und dabei
bleibt
und gleichzeitig ist es so
dass ich aber finde dass man
immer
überlegen muss wo geht es zu weit und
darum habe ich zum Beispiel als am
Anfang des Krieges einige gesagt haben
wir müssen jetzt eine
Flugverbotszone eine no-flight-zone
einrichten gesagt nein das geht nicht
das führt zu einer unmittelbaren
Eskalation des Krieges dann sind
nato-Flugzeuge im Kampf mit russischen
Flugzeugen das werden wir nicht tun und
im übrigen hat der amerikanische
Präsident das gleiche gesagt wie auch
jetzt wieder aktuell als die Diskussion
nun ganz plötzlich losging über die
Frage Kampfflugzeuge also deshalb kann
ich Ihnen sagen wir bleiben bei diesem
Kurs und darauf können Sie sich
verlassen es wird abgewogen bleiben wir
werden uns mit anderen abstimmen und wir
werden jede Eskalation vermeiden die zu
einem Krieg zwischen Russland und der
Natur führt die zweite Frage
Diplomatie
die zweite Frage Diplomatie
da bin ich sehr für
und deshalb bin ich einer von den ganz
wenigen die immer mal wieder mit Putin
telefonieren ich war erst in Moskau und
habe mit ihm da gesprochen an diesem 7
Meter langen Tisch vier Stunden lang
und ich habe seither mit ihm immer
wieder telefoniert und ich habe auch vor
das weiter zu tun
natürlich
ist in diesen langen Gesprächen das so
wie man es sich vorstellt wir sind nicht
einer Meinung und das muss dann ja auch
gesagt werden
und es ist aber mein Anliegen diese
Gespräche zu führen weil natürlich klar
ist wie wir aus diesem Schlamassel
rauskommen Russland muss einsehen dass
es mit seiner Absicht sich ein Teil des
ukrainischen Territoriums mit Gewalt
anzueignen nicht durchkommt und muss
Puppen zurückziehen damit ein fairer
Frieden zwischen den beiden Ländern
möglich wird und das ist auch das was
ich öffentlich und nicht nur öffentlich
sage weil das der Weg ist nur mit dem
Hinweis auf die Diplomatie die richtig
ist er setzt man nicht dass wir die
Leute die jetzt unmittelbar angegriffen
werden können angegriffen werden alleine
lässt das wäre ja auch nicht
verantwortlich wenn die panzer rollen
und ein Land erobern wollen und dann
sage ich halt stopp gibt nur Partie dann
hören die Panzer nicht auf zu Rollen
sondern das was wir jetzt machen ist
dass wir die unterstützen damit das
nicht geschehen kann aber wir nicht auf
zu sprechen weil das ist klar am Ende
muss es einen Friedensvereinbarung geben
aber das kann kein ungerechter Frieden
sein der ein diktatfrieden Russlands
gegen die Ukraine ist und das ist glaube
ich das worum es jetzt geht
wir werden dann gerne hier die Dame in
dem Rot mein Name ist Anna Karl ich bin
engagiert in der verhandels- und
weltladenbewegung und ich möchte Sie
fragen was du Deutschland was tun Sie
um die Fluchtursachen zu beseitigen
wir helfen gern wenn Menschen vor
Verfolgung fliehen
aber tragen wir nicht zusätzlich dazu
bei dass sie fliehen weil wir die
wirtschaftlichen Grundlagen ihrer
Existenz ruinieren und den klimanotstand
beschleunigen
ein Beispiel
wir exportieren und subventionieren das
noch Hühner klein nach Afrika
das kann dort sehr billig verkauft
werden billiger als vor als die vor Ort
gehaltenen Hühner so dass es sich für
die Hühnerhalter dort nicht mehr lohnt
Hühner zu halten und sie damit ihre
wirtschaftliche Existenz verlieren
und wo bleibt da die
Ernährungssouveränität das heißt dass
ich die Bevölkerung von dem Boden auf
dem sie lebt auch ernähren kann
würden Sie bitte Ihre Frage müssen genau
hier müssen die verschiedenen
wirtschaftlichen Verträge zu den
ungerechtig die zu den Ungerechtigkeiten
geführt haben unter die Lupe und
verändert werden eine wichtige Aufgabe
oder eine Bitte für die Bundesregierung
ja schönen Dank für Ihre Frage und ich
will sehr konkret hat das Beispiel dass
sie genannt haben das habe ich auch
schon mal also an verschiedenen
Gelegenheiten angeführt und finde dass
wir uns immer hinterfragen müssen auch
mit der unserer europäischen
Handelspolitik ob wir nicht die Dinge
schlimmer machen mit dem was wir machen
denn das gehört ja zur Fairness dazu
dass wir eigenständige ökonomische
Entwicklung in Ländern Afrikas zum
Beispiel nicht behindern indem wir sagen
wir mal Produkte die wir selbst nicht
mehr brauchen dahin billigst exportieren
und die Bauern vor Ort keine
Möglichkeiten haben mit ihrer eigenen
Zucht gewissermaßen das auf dem Markt
noch zu verkaufen und deshalb ist das
eine berechtigte Kritik die auch immer
wieder bei allem was genau angeschaut
werden muss und das kann ich versichern
die Regierung versucht unsere
Möglichkeiten zu nutzen dass das nicht
geschieht ansonsten gibt es natürlich
viele Fluchtursachen nicht nur diese und
die wichtigste ist glaube ich in vielen
Ländern wenn diejenigen die dort
aufwachsen und leben keine Hoffnung
haben der Lebensstandard in vielen
Ländern der Welt ist dramatisch geringer
als in Deutschland selbst wenn man nur
die Mitgliedstaaten der Europäischen
Union einmal durchguckt und jeden in
jedem sich mal das
Durchschnittseinkommen oder das den
Mindestlohn anguckt dann wären das oft
Einkünfte bei denen jemand der hier
Grundsicherung bekommt mehr Geld
überwiesen bekommt als das was dort im
europäischen Nachbarland gezahlt wird
für jemanden der voll berufstätig ist
und das gilt natürlich wenn man weiter
weg ist noch viel mehr
und deshalb müssen wir eigene
Entwicklung machen weil natürlich wenn
jemand in seiner Nachbarschaft sieht es
kommt voran und meine Kinder und Enkel
haben auch eine gute Möglichkeit dann
wird es weniger geben die fliehen aus
diesen Umständen und Verhältnissen und
da haben wir auch eine Verantwortung zu
der ich mich bekenne und deshalb haben
wir auch die Mittel die wir für die
Entwicklungshilfe einsetzen immer weiter
angehoben in den letzten Jahren und
werden das haben werden also diese Linie
auch fortsetzen in der nächsten Zeit was
mir wichtig ist ist dass wir aber uns
auch nicht die Welt ein Stück zu einfach
machen weil selbst wenn wir alles
richtig machen und dafür setzen wir
beide uns ein sie und ich wieder mit
seinen Möglichkeiten
ist es trotzdem so dass Menschen fliehen
werden
einmal weil sie war schlimme Dinge
passieren Krieg Verfolgung alles
mögliche Diktatur
aber eben auch weil die Hoffnung auf ein
besseres Leben im so groß ist und
unglaubliche Risiken in Kauf genommen
wenn denn das dürfen wir nicht vergessen
manche Fluchtroute ist ja real mit
Lebensgefahr verbunden
und deshalb werden wir
Verständigung hinbekommen müssen mit
vielen der Länder wo viele herkommen die
nicht politisch verfolgt werden nicht
vor einem Krieg fliegen sondern einfach
nach einem besseren Leben suchen die
aber vermeiden dass viele diese
gefährliche Route wählen und der
wichtigste beste Weg ist dass wir zwei
Dinge miteinander verknüpfen
legale Wege der Migration
also das man mit Antrag Visum
kommen kann nicht jeder aber einige und
dafür die Verständigung mit den
Herkunftsländern dass sie wenn jemand
hier zu Unrecht ein Aufenthaltsstatus
begehrt
ihre eigene Staatsbürger wieder
zurücknehmen ich glaube das mit so einer
fairen Vereinbarung
dass eine bessere Chance gibt dass Leute
nicht gehen weil sie wissen wenn sie gar
keinen Asylgrund haben klappt das
vielleicht nicht aber andererseits
wissen es gibt einen legalen Weg auf den
könnte man ja auch setzen und das ist
glaube ich das was wichtig ist und das
passt dann ganz gut zusammen mit unserem
wegen unseres ökonomischen Erfolges
unsere wirtschaftlichen Stärke und
unseres deswegen notwendigen Fachkräfte
Bedarfs existierenden Nachfrage nach
Frauen und Männern die hier anpacken
wollen wir werden ja dieses Jahr noch
die Gesetze in denen das geschieht
verbessern und erleichtern damit wir den
Fortschritt den wir in den letzten
Jahren hatten mit der Freizügigkeit
innerhalb der Europäischen Union ein
bisschen nutzen können in dem auch aus
anderen Ländern der Welt Leute die
gebraucht werden in Krankenhäusern in
Fabriken wo auch immer in
it-entwicklungs
Studios und Büros dass die kommen können
und da passt es dann vielleicht zusammen
ausreichend beantwortet ja vielen Dank
dann ist da ganz vorne eine her mit
einem rosafarbenen Kragen genau da
Schulz schon schönen guten Abend mein
Name ist Patrick Fischer ich bin
Offizier bei der Bundeswehr und derzeit
in der deutschen Delegation in den
Niederlanden eingesetzt meine Frage
zielt dahin dass sie Kabinett ja hier
und da nicht ganz zur Ruhe kommt das ist
das ein oder andere Fettnäpfchen was
unsere ehemalige Verteidigungsministerin
mitgenommen hat Frau bärburg mit
missverständlichen Aussagen und zu guter
Letzt jetzt die Innenministerin die sich
ja um den Posten des hessischen
Ministerpräsidenten bzw der hessischen
Ministerpräsidentin beworben hat
ist das Amt des Innenministeriums nur
noch eine rückfallposition weil sie hat
gesagt sie möchte das Amt auch weiter
ausführen selbst wenn sie nicht gewählt
werden würde ist es nur noch eine
rückfallposition macht sie das ähm Abend
jetzt noch mit weiterhin mit vollem
Gewissen oder nicht zweite Frage waren
sie morgens manchmal laufen denken sich
welches Kabinett hat heute wieder die
Büchse der Pandora geöffnet
also auf die letzte Frage kann ich klar
Antworten nein das mache ich nicht ich
schlafe trotz aller schwierigen Zeiten
meistens ganz ordentlich und gucke dem
Tag immer ganz fröhlich entgegen aber
weniger scherzhaft ich glaube dass wir
jetzt vor großen Herausforderungen
stehen wo wir gute Leute brauchen der
Verteidigungsminister ist ein
erstklassiger Mann Boris Pistorius das
sehr sehr gut machen und hat viele viele
Erfahrungen gewonnen in den letzten
Jahren seiner politischen Tätigkeit und
das ist auch gut für die Bundeswehr denn
die ist ja das muss man sehr klar sagen
in den letzten Jahren ziemlich
zusammengespart worden wenn ich mir das
erlauben darf
alle Verteidigungsminister die das
gemacht hatten waren CSU oder CDU keiner
von der SPD den der zuletzt von der SPD
war Peter Stock haben die Soldaten
ziemlich gemocht nach meiner Erfahrung
und so wird es mit dem jetzigen auch
wieder sein und im übrigen haben wir
jetzt ja mit dem Sondervermögen von 100
Milliarden Euro dazu beigetragen dass
die Bundeswehr auch gut ausgestattet
werden kann was notwendig ist aber eine
Aufgabe die wirklich viel Kraft über
längere Zeit erfordert was die Frage
betrifft zu
der Innenministerin ich finde das ist
eine hochprofessionelle tolle Ministerin
die großartige Arbeit leistet und ich
weiß dass das eine Frau ist die hier
aufgewachsen ist die
Hessen ist die viele Jahre im Landtag
war und ich kann schon verstehen wenn
hier zu Lande viele denken so eine gute
Politikerin hätten wir ja gerne als
Ministerpräsidentin aber das ist das was
dann entschieden wird und wie Sie wissen
gibt es fast überall in Deutschland wenn
jemand wenn eine Wahl ansteht einen
Amtsinhaber oder eine Amtsinhaberin die
machen ihre Geschäfte weiter und
kandidieren wieder fürs Amt manchmal
gibt es Leute die kandidieren für einen
Amt und haben das dann gerade noch nicht
und so ist es praktisch jedes Mal und
ich unterstelle das noch niemand in
dieser Zeit seine Arbeit nicht gut
gemacht hat von nancifer von der ich
weiß dass es eine sehr sehr
pflichtbewusste Frau es kann nicht sagen
die wird jeden Tag alles tun für die
Aufgabe die sie hat
dann hier vorne die Dame mit den blonden
Haaren und dem grauen Hemd
hallo mein Name ist Rebecca flücker ich
bin pflegerische Leitung der Notaufnahme
des Uniklinikums in Marburg
meine Frage zittern sie haben vorhin
erwähnt dass sie 500 Millionen Euro für
die Pflege als Wertschätzung
ausgegeben haben leider ist das nur
nicht bei auch anderen relevanten mit
angekommen zum Beispiel der Notaufnahme
dem OP der Endoskopie dem Herzkatheter
Labor weil diese alle als
Funktionseinheit zählen und nicht als
bettenführende Station gibt es dafür
eine Begründung weil die habe ich bis
heute leider nicht gefunden warum diese
nicht berücksichtigt werden konnten in
Ihrem Paket
wir haben jetzt es gibt ja zwei Fragen
die in ihrer diese gestellt haben wenn
ich das so für mich mal zusammenfasst
ist eines was haben wir gemacht während
der Kurve 19 Pandemie in den letzten
Jahren und da haben wir versucht dass
die Krankenhäuser durchhalten können
indem wir ihnen auf die verschiedenen
Weise Geld zukommen lassen haben obwohl
sie wegen der Kurve 19 Patienten
gewissermaßen die
bestimmte Einnahmen nicht haben konnten
weil sie den Betrieb umgestellt haben
weil sie Betten frei geräumt haben
Pflegekräfte anders disponiert haben
damit das funktioniert und nun geht es
allmählich wieder raus aus dieser
Situation jetzt müssen wir uns überlegen
wie können wir für die Zukunft unser
Gesundheitssystem besser organisieren
und da hat der Gesundheitsminister eine
große große krankenhausreform vor die in
Deutschland viele viele Jahrzehnte
überfällig ist und bestimmte
Unwuchten und davon gibt es ganz schön
viele in unserem Gesundheitssystem aber
insbesondere in der Frage der
Krankenhausversorgung zu verändern und
das was dazu erforderlich ist ist dass
er sagt wir wollen das System das heute
die Frage steuert wie werden
Krankenhäuser finanziert die
Kostenpauschalen die ARDS heißt das für
die Eingeweihten
das wollen wir ändern nicht den wir es
komplett abschaffen aber in dem es nicht
mehr so eine entscheidende Bedeutung hat
die Grundidee der von vielen Fachleuten
jetzt erarbeiten Reform ist dass es für
Krankenhäuser eine Grundleistung gibt
die so bei 60 Prozent liegt so dass sie
jetzt nicht um jeden einzelnen Fall
kämpfen müssen sondern einfach eine gute
Versorgung gewährleisten können und
gleichzeitig dass man aber im Sinne der
Patienten und der Qualität des Angebotes
für das hier stehen wenn ich das richtig
gesehen habe sicherstellen kann dass
nicht dass die kräftige bündelt werden
das wäre also dort wo man was möglichst
oft machen musste damit man es auch gut
macht das auch dort diese Leistung
konzentriert werden das also
Krankenhäuser die bestimmte komplizierte
Operation anbieten die auch oft machen
und alle haben was man dazu braucht und
diese bessere Mischung die den das jetzt
kostenregime den Druck der heute
existiert völlig wenn dann in ein
besseres Angebot das ist das was jetzt
endlich angepackt wird und ich bin ganz
zuversichtlich dass das gelingt diese
wirklich große Reform zustande zu
bringen sie wäre schon längst nötig
gewesen
es ist leider noch nicht ganz
beantwortet okay ist noch nicht
ausreichend beantwortet okay also mir
fehlt tatsächlich die Notfallmedizin
definitiv drin weil die Notfallmedizin
ist nie ein Plus das ist so ja wir
leisten da unglaublich viel wir rettener
Menschen leben ja und leider wird die
Notfallmedizin aber immer ganz hinten
mit angestellt und leider ist es wie
gesagt auch von der corona-prämie die
Ende jetzt letzten Jahres ausgezahlt
wurde in Funktionsbereichen wie
Notaufnahmen OP Endoskopien Herzkatheter
Laboren nichts angekommen warum wurden
diese nicht berücksichtigt ja wir haben
jetzt bei der den Zahlung die wir
gemacht haben um die zu unterstützen die
ganz konkret in diesem unmittelbaren
Einsatz sind natürlich bestimmte
Vorschläge gemacht wie das gehen kann
tatsächlich ist ja die echte Aussage für
das Gesundheitswesen man müsste
eigentlich überall mehr Geld hin tun das
wissen jedenfalls die Beteiligten ganz
gut zu beschreiben und deshalb will ich
das noch mal sagen das was wir jetzt
hinkriegen wollen ist eine langfristige
Reform die aber sehr schnell kommen soll
in der wir all die Probleme die dazu
führen dass einzelne Bereiche sich nicht
gut behandelt fühlen dass wir die
beseitigen dauerhaft und für die Zukunft
so dass man damit gut planen kann so
dass das besser wird für die
Patientinnen und Patienten aber auch
besser für diejenigen die
krankenhausleistung anbieten und die vor
allem jeden Tag ganz tolle schwierige
Arbeit in den Krankenhäusern leisten ich
hoffe dass sie sie jetzt als besser
beantwortet Betrachten der Herr hier in
dem Rot Schwarz kommt
ja schönen guten Abend ich möchte mich
noch mal dem Vorredner in dem
gestreiften Hemd anschließen er hat ja
gefordert mehr Diplomatie das finde ich
auch man kann mit Waffenlieferung keine
Kriege beenden sondern es braucht die
platomie ich möchte noch mal gerne
zitieren ihren Vorgänger den Altkanzler
Helmut Schmidt der hat mal gesagt lieber
100 Stunden umsonst verhandeln als eine
Minute schießen und Frage dazu sie stand
ja im letzten Jahr neben dem
amerikanischen Präsidenten beiden in den
USA der sagte Nord Stream 2 Werte nicht
ans Netz gehen ohne gegen diese Drohung
konkret zu protestieren im letzten Jahr
wurde dann die Leitung gesprengt Frage
von wem und Zusatzfrage wie unabhängig
ist eigentlich Deutschland und Europa
von der Welt macht USA USA die zeitweise
Menschenrechte die im Irakkrieg im Lager
Guantanamo und bei den Drohnen worden
mit Füßen tritt
ich glaube
dass man jetzt mal alles mögliche sagen
kann aber an einem nicht vorbei reden
und auch nicht vorbei Fragen kann
nämlich dies ist ein imperialistischer
Angriffskrieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine die mit Gewalt versuchen sich
einen Teil des Nachbar Territoriums ohne
jeden Grund anzueignen und dafür in Kauf
nehmen dass sie nur verbrannte Erde
hinterlassen zerstörte Städte zerstörte
störfer zerstörte Eisenbahnlinien
zerstörte Straßen und jetzt im Winter
mit großer Absicht Raketen schießen
lassen auf
energieversorgungsinfrastruktur damit es
kalt wird und möglichst viele Leute aus
der Ukraine fliehen das ist die Politik
die Russland macht und ich hoffe dass
wir uns darüber einig sind dass das die
Realität ist
ja aber jetzt sie rufen jetzt dann hat
nicht jeder verstanden
NATO-Osterweiterung ich sage Ihnen
gleich was dazu aber noch mal sie müssen
ihre Worte dann auch ernst nehmen wenn
Sie wenn Sie das Wort nato-ost
Erweiterung und ich komme gleich dazu
verwenden um zu sagen damit ist dieser
Krieg von Russland gerechtfertigt
ja gut den Satz wollte ich einmal hören
sie haben gesagt und ich hoffe das
werden sie jeden Tag einmal sagen dieser
Krieg ist nicht gerechtfertigt dieser
Krieg ist unberechtigt ist furchtbar er
ist mörderisch und er ist
imperialistisch und er ist von Russland
bekommen
aber ich will auf Ihre Fragen eingehen
erstens wer die Pipeline hochgesprengt
hat kann man vermuten aber weil wir ein
Rechtsstaat sind vermuten wir nicht
sondern sagen nur dann etwas ganz
präzises wenn wir das beweisen können
und deshalb macht es gar keinen Sinn
dahin und her zu erwägen auch wenn hier
wahrscheinlich fast alle denken dass wir
das ist finde ich darf man sich nicht in
Spekulation ergeben wir waren zum
Beispiel ganz genau als die beiden
Raketen aus der Ukraine
die Abwehrraketen nicht dahin gepflogen
sind wo sie sollten sondern in Polen
gelandet sind und zwei Bauern getötet
haben da haben wir verhindert das gesagt
wird das war von Russland sondern wir
haben alle gesagt alles was wir sehen
spricht dafür dass das so ein Unfall war
und wir haben auch das gesagt das
spricht ein bisschen dafür dass man
trauen kann dass wir in dieser Frage
immer genau bleiben und deshalb kann ich
Ihnen sagen zu Nord Stream können wir
uns dann äußern wenn wir Beweise haben
und die für jeden Staatsanwalt und für
jedes Gerichtsverfahren in Deutschland
verwendbar sind und solange das dann
nicht der Fall ist müssen wir so
zurückhaltend reden wie wir das tun
was die Frage betrifft
der nato-ost-erweiterung
erstmal das war schon ganz schön toll
das viele Länder
die hinter dem Eisernen Vorhang waren
und die mit Gewalt daran gehindert
wurden Demokratien zu sein und ihre
Freiheit zu erobern nach 1990 so wie wir
in Deutschland die Möglichkeit bekommen
haben in Demokratie zu leben wir haben
unser Land wieder vereinen können und
eine gemeinsame Deutsche Demokratische
Bundesrepublik Deutschland geschaffen
großartig die Wiedervereinigung und
viele Länder im Osten Europas haben ihre
Freiheit bekommen und die Demokratie
wieder gewonnen in den baltischen
Staaten in Polen in Tschechien in der
Slowakei in Rumänien in Bulgarien in
Ungarn in den ganzen Staaten die zum
ehemaligen Jugoslawien gehört haben in
Albanien
das sind und Rumänien habe ich glaube
ich noch nicht gesagt also das sind ganz
ganz viele Länder großartig die haben
die Freiheit bekommen und in der
Freiheit diese gewonnen haben haben Sie
gesagt Sie wollen zur Europäischen Union
dazu gehören da kann man doch nicht
sagen das sollen sie nicht
und in dieser Zeit haben sie für sich
entschieden dass sie ihre eigene
Sicherheit und Verteidigung besser
organisiert kriegen wenn Sie das mit uns
zusammen in der NATO machen aber das ist
der ein gutes Recht und es war auch
richtig dass wir in die Möglichkeit dazu
gegeben haben denn die NATO ist dass wir
dich für mich jedenfalls klar sagen kein
gefährliches angriffsbündnis sondern ein
Verteidigungsbündnis es gibt auch wenn
man sich die konkreten Waffen ansieht
keinerlei Infrastrukturen die aggressiv
sind gegenüber Russland und es gibt der
Verteidigung und deshalb will ich im
Hinblick auf NATO etwas zu Ukraine sagen
ich war ja in Moskau ich war auch vorher
in Kiew und hat mit selenski gesprochen
und ich habe in beiden Städten gesagt
NATO-Beitritt der Ukraine steht jetzt
hier echt nicht auf der Tagesordnung
ich habe sogar in Moskau neben Putin
stehend gesagt das passiert die nächsten
30 Jahre nicht
und trotzdem
hat dieses Argument dass das passieren
könnte einen der fadenscheinigen
unglaubwürdigen Kriegsgründe für Putin
geliefert obwohl er wusste dass das
nicht passiert und obwohl er wusste dass
niemand vor hat irgendwelche Raketen in
der Ukraine zu stationieren die auf
Moskau gerichtet sein können das war
alles vorgeschoben für eine lange
durchgeführten Plan
nämlich einfach so ein bisschen das
russische Territorium mit Gewalt zu
vergrößern und deshalb finde ich sollte
man nicht so den Eindruck erwecken dass
man indem man so ein Wort wie NATO Ost
Erweiterung oder sonst was in den Raum
wirft irgendwie verstehbar macht warum
Russland das getan hat dafür und für
diesen Krieg gab es keinen akzeptablen
rationalen Grund
ich weiß dass es da unheimlich viel
Redebedarf gibt und das ist ein sehr
emotionales Thema ist aber wir möchten
natürlich so viel wie möglich
Teilnehmenden die Möglichkeit geben ihre
Fragen zu stellen auch wenn da
unheimlich viel Redebedarf ist wo gibt
es noch Fragen die Dame hier in der
ersten Reihe mit dem schwarzen Pulli
vielleicht ein Moment des Mikrofon kommt
dann können Sie Ihre Frage stellen
ja ich meinte eigentlich sorry ich
meinte die Terme rechts
Entschuldigung okay
schönen guten Abend mein Name ist Jan
ich komme aus Stadtallendorf und meine
Frage ist neue Handelspartner also diese
Abhängigkeit einfach dass man da
rauskommt man sieht es jetzt an dem
russlandkrieg man war richtig abhängig
jetzt gerade auch von Gas von Energien
wie sieht das aus mit den neuen
Handelspartnern haben wir da jetzt mehr
breiteres Spektrum und einfach neue
Handel also neue Handelspartner wo wir
Energie beziehen können einfach aus
dieser Abhängigkeit raus was hat da die
Bundesregierung
zunächst mal das war schon schwierig für
uns dass wir so abhängig waren von
russischen Gast auch von Kohle und Öl
aber vor allem von russischen Gas von
dem Gast dass wir in Deutschland
benötigen
das sind glaube ich wenn ich zum Kopf
habe knapp 100 Milliarden Kubikmeter
haben wir 50 Prozent aus Russland
bekommen
das ist eine ganz schöne Menge
und deshalb haben alle gedacht wir
kommen jetzt diesen Winter in die Kälte
und haben alle gedacht die Wirtschaft
bricht ein beides haben wir vermieden
weil wir in ganz kurzer Zeit das gemacht
haben was wir schon immer hätten machen
müssen nämlich gegen das russische
gastsprach ja gar nichts
nämlich dafür zu sorgen dass wir von
einem Tag auf dem anderen den
Lieferanten wechseln können hätten wir
also diese Terminals die wir jetzt Stück
für Stück an der norddeutschen Küste
bauen schon immer gehabt und sei es nur
um sie einmal im Jahr zu putzen und zu
gucken ob sie funktionieren und dann
weiter zu pflegen dann hätten wir es
jetzt nicht so schwierig gehabt
ganz schnell die gastversorgung
umzustellen jetzt haben wir das gemacht
mit dramatischen Entscheidungen wir
haben 20 Kohlekraftwerke wieder laufen
lassen was mir wirklich wegen des Klimas
nicht gut gefällt aber wir haben gesagt
bis April 24 wir lassen die drei
Atomkraftwerke bis zum April diesen
Jahres weiterlaufen dann ist allerdings
Schluss wir haben mehr Gast importiert
über die westeuropäischen Häfen die
Norweger geben uns mehr und wir bauen
diese norddeutschen Terminals und die
Speicher haben wir auch voll gemacht das
hat uns alles durch diese Sache geholfen
aber hätten wir vorher die Möglichkeiten
Verb dass wir mal von dem mal von dem
was kriegen und nicht alle Eier in einen
Korb gelegt dann wäre es besser gewesen
das haben wir geändert und das werden
wir auch dauerhaft ändern das wird aber
Konsequenzen für uns haben denn
natürlich ist das jetzt nicht nur in
Sachen Russland und Gas sondern auch bei
vielen anderen Sachen übrigens auch von
vielen Unternehmen viele Jahre immer so
gemacht worden wo ist der eine der das
am billigsten in der ganzen Welt macht
und dann haben die obwohl die alle im
dritten Semester
Betriebswirtschaftslehre an der Uni
gelernt haben nicht alle Eier in einen
Korb legen es Tracht getan weil es
einfach so billig war und weil es so
verführerisch war
das dürfen wir nicht wieder machen jetzt
müssen wir das Stück für Stück was
Exportmärkte und liefermärkte betrifft
also Lieferketten betrifft dafür sorgen
dass wir ein breiteres Spektrum haben
das tun wir
Konsequenz es wird ein bisschen teurer
da sollten wir uns nichts vormachen weil
das andere war ja so billig und darum
ist es passiert nicht weil
irgendjemanden politisches Konzept hatte
und das zweite ist
wir werden auch mithelfen müssen wenn
wir sagen wir wollen jetzt bestimmte
Rohstoffe nicht nur China bekommen das
anderswo diese Rohstoffe aus dem Boden
geholt werden dass sie verarbeitet
werden und dass sie genutzt werden
können da sind in der Vergangenheit der
eine und die andere bei uns ein bisschen
zu fein gewesen also die haben gedacht
aber mit der Frage wo wir die herkriegen
beschäftigen uns nicht weiter und das
wird nicht geben also entweder oder aber
wir haben was anzubieten das habe ich
jetzt auch als ich in Argentinien in
Chile war und Brasilien gemacht und das
freut die auch dass wir nämlich ein Land
sind das ja nun Ziele hat die ganz gut
passen zu diesen Ländern wir sind dafür
dass die sozialen Fragen beachtet werden
vor Ort mit der Bevölkerung die dort
lebt dass die Umweltbedingungen beachtet
werden das ist auch neue Beschäftigung
und diesen Ländern gibt wir wollen das
nicht nur rausholen und alles nach
Deutschland Karren und das sind die
Chancen die wir haben wenn wir fair zu
anderen sind haben wir die Chance dass
wir davon auch noch profitieren
weil das eben gerade so ein
Missverständnis war von formulieren Sie
gerade nebendran noch ihre Frage sie
hatten vorhin schon angefangen zu
sprechen ja vielen Dank zum ersten
möchte ich einfach sagen dass ich froh
bin dass sie so zögerlich sind dass sie
warten und abwägen und gerade was den
Krieg betrifft bin ich Ihnen dankbar
dafür und ich
möchte an der Stelle sagen bitte fahren
Sie den Kurs so weiter und meine Frage
ist jetzt gerade wo wir jetzt face to
face hier sind sie waren mit Putin sie
waren mit zielensky face to face bitte
sagen sie schätzen sie ein wann streckt
Putin die Waffen was muss passieren dass
er aufhört
tja
das ist eine
wirklich schwierig zu beantwortende
Frage aber die
Antwort aber die Frage ist erstmal
völlig berechtigt es muss zu sein dass
der russische Präsident
versteht dass er sein Ziel nicht
erreichen wird darum sage ich immer er
darf den Krieg nicht gewinnen
und dass er ein Schritt machen muss zu
einer fairen Verständigung zwischen den
beiden Ländern dann gibt es das will ich
ausdrücklich sagen unglaublich viel
Bereitschaft und unglaublich vielen
Willen in der Ukraine und auch anderswo
alles dafür zu tun dass das dann auch
möglich wird aber den einen Schritt
gewissermaß zu sagen jetzt beginnt eine
neue
Phase den muss er schon einleiten und
das ist das
wir müssen ja darauf setzen und deshalb
habe ich ja auch gesagt werde ich egal
was öffentlich geredet wird
der Diplomatie sprechen
danke schön
da vorne der Herr mit der schwarzen
Mütze neben der Kamera
mein Name ist Phil Morgentau ich komme
hier aus Warburg Marburg und ich habe
eine Verständnisfrage sie sagten im Mai
2022 auf dem Katholikentag in Stuttgart
ich sage mal ganz ehrlich diese schwarz
gekleideten Inszenierungen bei
verschiedenen Veranstaltungen von immer
den gleichen Leuten erinnern mich an
einer Zeit die lange zurückliegt und
Gott sei Dank in Richtung von
klimaaktivistin meine Frage in dessen
Nähe rücken sie damit semantisch die
klima-bewegung ist das A französisch
also ich will in ihre Frage gerne
beantworten wer da da versucht hat das
Podium zu stürmen wusste ich zu der Zeit
nicht als ich mich darauf Zuge äußert
habe was da eigentlich stattfindet das
nämlich versucht wurde irgendwie
gewalttätig eine auf dem Kirchentag
stattfindende Demonstration zu kapern
fand ich keine gute Idee finde ich immer
noch nicht
hier vorne ist eine Wortmeldung am
Stehtisch die Dame mit dem weißen Pulli
ja danke schön ich gehe davon aus dass
ich jetzt nicht noch mal dran komme
deswegen werde ich jetzt alle fünf
Fragen stelle
bitte dann die herzensfrage also mein
Name ist Dunja Hilgenberg ich bin jetzt
hierin hier in der Grundschule in
Marburg und muss auf den Punkt zu
bringen herr Scholz ich habe Angst dass
Russland Deutschland angreift wer sich
immer mehr in die Enge getrieben fühlt
greift zu allen Mitteln die ihn zur
Verfügung stehen um sich zu wehren oder
er gibt auf ich weiß das ist die
Hoffnung die hinter der panzerlieferung
und was noch alles so zu Unterstützung
der Ukraine aus anderen naturländern
geliefert werden
diese Hoffnung wieder hinter steht aber
das ist ein druckschloss was hier
geschieht kannst du immer weitere
Ausweitung des Krieges führen meine
Bitte an Sie Herr Scholz als
Bundeskanzler einer Partei die mit Willy
Brandt gesagt hat von unserem Land soll
nie wieder Krieg ausgehen
fragen sie bitte Putin ob er zu
Verhandlungen jetzt bereit ist der
brasilianische Präsident Lula hat sich
als Moderator angeboten es müssen
Kompromisse gefunden werden wie in allen
Konflikten ich erwarte von uns Menschen
im 21 Jahrhundert dass wir zum Reden
bereit sind und das Töten ein Ende hat
[Applaus]
erstmal
ist es wichtig dass man sich überhaupt
klar macht die Gefahr von Eskalation ist
immer da und deshalb ist es auch richtig
und ich sage das hier noch mal dass wir
uns genau überlegen was wir machen dass
wir nicht
alleine marschieren dass wir uns die
eskalationsgefahren
klar machen und dass wir auch
schrittweise agieren und nicht alles auf
einmal machen was ja auch einige fordern
sondern das hat alles einen guten Sinn
gleichzeitig muss man
verhindern dass absurde Dinge passieren
deshalb habe ich mir schon genau
angeguckt was aus Russland alles so
gesagt wurde
und deshalb war es mir ganz wichtig und
dafür hat es ja Kritik gegeben die
hinterher ziemlich verstummt war
deshalb bin ich auch nach China Gefahren
unter anderem es war sowieso mal Zeit
das ist schlecht wenn man mit solchen
wichtigen Regierungen nicht redet und
wegen Co wird nur noch am Telefon oder
per Videotelefonie diskutiert
bin ich nach China gefahren habe mit dem
chinesischen Präsidenten skigebrochen
und wir beide haben öffentlich
im Peking erklärt
es dürfen keine Atomwaffen eingesetzt
werden das ist eine rote Linie die nicht
überschritten werden darf
und das hat dazu geführt dass das dann
noch mal ein Beschluss der G20-Staaten
wenige Tage später in Indonesien
geworden ist ohne diese
Aktion diese Reise und diese Erklärung
wäre das wahrscheinlich sehr schwer
gefallen aber so ist es gelungen dass
wir nicht nur eine sehr klare
Stellungnahme auch der G20 sowieso ja
der UN-Generalversammlung gegen den
russischen Angriffskrieg bekommen haben
sondern dass wir auch diese Aussage
haben und seitdem hört man das ab und zu
immer mal wieder aber das ist doch
anders geworden weil das war dann doch
unmissverständlich auch in die Richtung
Russlands
die Chinesen wissen in dieser Frage
genau es gibt keinen
Atomkrieg der kleinen ist und ein nicht
betrifft und deshalb war das ganz
wichtig das zu sagen
was jetzt die Frage betrifft reden
verhandeln ich meine ich könnte jetzt
mal irgendwie einen bitten die Stunden
zusammen zu zählen aber auf die schon
vorhin irgendwo geforderten 100 Stunden
zu wenig glaube ich noch nicht ganz aber
fast gekommen was das Sprechen betrifft
aber der eigentliche Weg muss ja sein
dass die russische Regierung ablässt von
dem Plan sich mit Gewalt möglichst viel
ukrainisches Territorium anzueignen und
dem Augenblick in dem sie erkennen
lassen und es ist der Weg ist
Truppenrückzug in dem Augenblick ist
auch der Weg für Gespräche mit der
Ukraine da bin ich ziemlich sicher frei
und auch die Möglichkeit sich zu
verständigen aber das wird da müssen wir
noch ein bisschen darauf hinarbeiten
dann gehen wir hier vorne gerade noch
mal in die erste Reihe zu dem Herrn der
auf dem dritten Platz sitzt mit dem
schwarzen zipper
das sind sie genau gut erkannt
ja Herr Scholz sie haben vorhin erwähnt
dass sie im Kinder- und Jugendparlament
auch Fragen zum Krieg gestellt bekommen
haben
ich finde das erschreckend ich würde mir
eine Welt Wünschen in der Kinder solche
Fragen nicht stellen weil Erwachsene in
der Lage sind ihre Konflikte anders zu
lösen das war aber nur der sozusagen
Vorgeschmack worauf ich hinaus will ist
sie sind Jurist es gibt inzwischen
ernst zu nehmende Professoren ihres
Faches die sagen dass sie die Büchse der
Pandora geöffnet haben dadurch dass sie
jetzt diese panzerlieferung was
Deutschland noch nie gemacht hat in der
Kriegsgebiet zugelassen haben
soll heißen wenn demnächst solche
Forderungen kommen in den mannigfaltigen
kriegen dieser Welt dann können Sie das
oder spätere Bundesregierung zwar
ablehnen aber juristisch werden sie dann
durch die Rüstungsindustrie dazu
gezwungen es zuzulassen oder hohe
Entschädigungen zu zahlen 1 sehen Sie
das auch so zweitens wie wollen Sie wie
wollen Sie das verhindern und das geht
ja deutlich über die Situation hinaus
dass es hier darum geht einen Staat der
völkerrechtlich das Recht hat sich zu
verteidigen das sind doch immer Dinge da
werden so scheindiskussionen aufgeführt
natürlich ist uns allen klar dass das
völkerrechtlich was Russland gemacht hat
so nicht hinnehmbar ist völlig logisch
verzweifelt denn daran und sie ist auch
völlig klar Hinblick auf die Zeit ihre
Fragen
stellen gerne wissen wie schätzen Sie
das zukünftig ein das geht über das Hier
und Jetzt weiter hinaus danke
also die Frage kann ich Ihnen ganz klar
beantworten nein ein solcher
juristischer Zwang existiert überhaupt
nicht und ich kann auch nicht
nachvollziehen wie irgendjemand auch nur
auf die Idee kommen kann wenn ich das
mal ganz klar sagen ja Professor für
Rechtswissenschaften gibt es viele wenn
ich das als Jurist mal sagen darf so
aber an dieser Frage ist ziemlich klar
das ist Homburg und ich will ihnen das
auch sehr erklären
dass wir keine also völkerrechtliches
völlig klar man darf jeden Staat mit
Waffen unterstützen auch im Kriegsfall
und eine Beteiligung entsteht
völkerrechtlich nur wenn man eigene
Soldaten dahin schickt das werden wir in
keinem Fall tun
politisch ist die Frage komplizierter
deshalb bekenne ich mich zu meinem
abgewogenen Vorgehen zum Abstimmen mit
anderen und dass man sich genau überlegt
was man tut und was man nicht tut
was die Waffenlieferung betrifft ist das
das absolute Hoheitsrechte des Staates
wir müssen niemanden auch nur irgendeine
Waffenlieferung genehmigen wenn
Deutschland beschließen würde wir
liefern überhaupt niemanden Waffen
könnte uns niemand daran ändern und
deshalb ist es so dass wir dazu auch
geordnete Verfahren haben und es gibt
viele Anträge die wir bekommen für
Waffenlieferungen alle Welt die wir
nicht befürworten nein das ist immer
noch das geltende Recht und es gibt
sogar sehr abgestufte Verfahren selbst
wenn jemand sagt darf ich mich da
bewerben und wir sagen bewirb Dich mal
sind wir nicht verpflichtet das
hinterher zu genehmigen selbst wenn wir
das Go gegeben haben sind wir nicht
verpflichtet hinterher die
Exportgenehmigung auch tatsächlich zu
erteilen es gibt so bestimmte Abstufung
aber wenn irgendjemand den Humbug
erfunden hat weil wir einmal in einem
Gebiet Waffen geliefert haben müssen wir
in jedes andere Gebiet Waffen liefern
muss man wirklich sagen das lässt sich
niemals aus irgendeiner rechtlichen
Struktur dieses Landes ableiten das
demokratische Hoheitsrecht des Staates
ist dass die Wirtschaft sich hier nach
uns der Demokratie und dem Staat zu
richten hat und es gibt auch keine
andere Gesetzgebung
danke schön wir schauen dann zur
nächsten Frage vielen Dank und zwar hier
vorne
da Moment als auf das Mikro warten
und da ist es auch schon
bitteschön ja mein Name ist Moni
heimbach-rosbach ich leide eine 7 Gruppe
gepädagogische Einrichtung mit ein 40
Kolleginnen und 144 Kinder mit ihren
Familien wir kämpfen gerade mit den
Folgen von Corona natürlich
meine Frage dahin wer einmal wo können
wir da Unterstützung finden werden wir
gehört viele Kollegen haben das Handtuch
geworfen weil während der Pandemie wir
wenig vorgekommen sind
und auch ungeschützt gearbeitet haben
über einen langen Zeitraum das haben die
Kollegen gemacht und ich muss aus meiner
Einrichtung sagen die sind auch nach wie
vor motiviert und wir machen das mit
Leidenschaft und gerne aber trotzdem
merken wir die Rahmenbedingungen reichen
nicht aus um all das was hier eben jeder
Bereich der heute abend angesprochen ist
findet bei uns im Hause statt Krieg
Ukraine Syrien Armut das trifft sich
alles bei wir brauchen da zukünftig mehr
Erzieherinnen und Erzieher auf jeden
Fall
Zugangsvoraussetzungen Schulen
Ausbildung das ist was was ich an die
Bundesregierung richten würde und als
zweites haben mich habe ich sehr
besorgte Eltern auch in der Einrichtung
die sich im Moment wirklich fragen wo
bekomme ich Antibiotika für Scharlach wo
bekomme ich den Fiebersaft die sitzen
bei mir war in dem Büro weil wir die
konkret wissen ja am besten das von den
Eltern also das wäre mir das Wichtigste
weil das brennt
die wissen nicht wo ist es Antibiotika
hernehmen sollen ne ja also
ich möchte mich erstmal für ihre Arbeit
im Einsatz und denen ihrer Kolleginnen
und Kollegen bedanken dass es immer eine
schwere Arbeit die unglaublich viel Herz
erfordert aber es ist natürlich jetzt
wenn der Gruppe 19 Pandemie noch viel
schwieriger gewesen mit all den
Einschränkungen Beschränkung und
natürlich auch den Herausforderungen die
dann von überall da rein getragen werden
also in ihrer Arbeit und dass sie das
machen dass sie da jeden Tag wieder
hingehen und dass sie das mit Herzblut
machen das wirklich verdient jeder
Anerkennung die möchte ich hier auch mal
aussprechen
ich bin fest davon überzeugt wir
brauchen am Ende in Deutschland ein
flächendeckendes Angebot an Krippen und
Kitas mit ausreichend vielen Erziehern
Erziehern wir haben ja jetzt sogar
gesetzlich ein Aufbau gemacht das
überall in Deutschland die Grundschulen
Ganztagsangebote haben was in einigen
Ländern in Deutschland der Fall ist auch
in dem indem ich mal Bürgermeister war
in Hamburg aber anderswo eben nicht und
ich glaube dass das gut ist wenn wir das
hinkriegen
das bedeutet aber dass wir jetzt die
Entscheidung treffen müssen die wir
vielleicht vor Jahrzehnten hätten
treffen müssen nämlich genügend
erziehernerzieher Auszubildenden
Lehrerinnen Lehrer übrigens auch das
Thema kommt jetzt ja auch wie
Weihnachten ist immer plötzlich und das
ist diese Situation in der wir uns jetzt
befinden
und da kann ich nur sagen das muss jetzt
geschehen da müssen wir uns untergreifen
wir haben als Bundesregierung nicht
gesagt wir gucken mal ins Grundgesetz
wir sind unzuständig werden nämlich so
sondern haben gesagt wir legen Programme
auf indem wir diesen Ausbau von Krippen
und Kitas voranbringen indem wir helfen
das genügend Ausbildungsmöglichkeiten
geschaffen werden und natürlich wollen
wir auch dass die Berufe attraktiver
werden das hat was mit Bezahlungen
Arbeitsbedingungen zu tun aber natürlich
auch mit der von ihnen zu Recht
verlangten Anerkennung das will ich
ausdrücklich dazu sagen und wenn alle
wissen ist ein toller Beruf und sich
Frauen und Männer entscheiden das zu
machen dann glaube ich wäre das ein ganz
ganz großer Fortschritt ich jedenfalls
bin beeindruckt von all denjenigen die
das machen und wenn sich jetzt jemand
entscheidet Erzieherin zu werden oder
Erzieher
und das macht man ja in ganz jungen
Jahren
und dann macht man das bis 67
und geht dann mit 66 in die Kita und
dann sind da Kinder in 30 Jahren die
sind ganz anders als heute das kann man
ja nur machen wenn man die richtige
Einstellung dazu hat also das finde ich
wirklich und da wünsche ich mir dass das
ganz viele tun was das Thema betrifft
der Medikamentenversorgung
ist es so dass wir gucken dass es
Ausweichmöglichkeiten gibt also manchmal
ist es so dass man ein anderes benutzen
kann als das was man verschrieben
bekommen hat aber das hilft ja nur ein
bisschen der Gesundheitsminister hat
jetzt ein sofortpaket gemacht und wir
machen noch ein längerfristiges
gesetzgeberisches dass die Tatsache wir
hatten das schon billig billig billig
ein bisschen bekämpft also in seinen
Vorschlägen ist zum Beispiel drin das
bei Ausschreibung für Medikamente in dem
Gesundheitssystem gesagt werden muss es
muss auch eine Tranche geben für ein
Angebot das auch lokal vorhanden ist
dass man vorschreibt das bestimmte
Lagerbestände in der Nähe vorhanden sein
müssen und dass man wo es
Mangelsituation gibt und dass sie
schneller erkennt indem das System
verbessert wird und dann mit höheren
Vergütungen dafür sorgt dass diese
Mangelsituation
nicht da sind das ganz konkrete Problem
weiß nicht ob es eine Ausrede ist aber
das lese ich immer wenn ich diese ganzen
Schilderung bekommt das ganze das
Problem ist natürlich auch damit
verbunden dass sich wegen der
covid-pandemie alle die so
Wirtschaftlichkeit kulieren wie viel
produziere ich denn nun um das zu
verkaufen gedacht haben naja die
Infektionen sind ja zurückgegangen denn
als wir alle die Maske getragen haben
ist ja nicht nur Corona weniger geworden
sondern eben auch alles andere und
plötzlich ist es alles wieder da so und
mehr so und das ist natürlich jetzt der
Grund warum es diese Mangelsituation
kommt aber wir haben das zum anders
genommen der Gesundheitsminister jetzt
sofort alle Maßnahmen zu ergreifen damit
wir ein gutes Angebot haben
ich hoffe es ist ausreichend beantwortet
Dankeschön wir haben jetzt noch knapp 20
Minuten und wir schauen wo es noch
Fragen gibt der Herr in dem blauen Pulli
in der zweiten Reihe mit der Brille
das Mikrofon kommt sofort zu Ihnen
und dann freuen wir uns auf Ihre Frage
guten Bundeskanzler mein Name ist Volker
stark ich habe eine Frage zum Thema
Energiepolitik wir hören und lesen
Seiten paar Tagen das sehr viele
staatliche Subventionen gibt für
Unternehmen beispielsweise in den USA
oder jetzt kürzlich erst in der EU von
der Leyen und auch in Deutschland meine
Frage welche konkreten Maßnahmen und
Unterstützungen planen Sie für private
Haushalte zum Beispiel für
Photovoltaikanlagen oder Stromspeicher
damit wir die Energieversorgung jetzt
sicherstellen können und Energie
Engpässe in der Zukunft vermeiden können
ja zunächst mal ist Ihre Frage ja ein
bisschen subventionskritisch
da haben Sie auch einen Punkt will ich
ausdrücklich dazu sagen denn wenn man
sagt ich gebe jetzt für diese Sache Geld
dann gibt es ja nicht nur die Leute die
sagen das will ich haben meistens mit
dem Zusatz wieso so wenig sondern dann
gibt es auch noch die nächsten die sich
melden und sagen wieso ich nicht also
das ist man kommt da irgendwie schnell
ins Unterholz das muss man sehr klar
sagen trotzdem haben wir ja seit Jahren
was gemacht damit wir es hinbekommen
dass wir den Umstieg auf die
erneuerbaren Energien auch tatsächlich
hinbekommen und da müssen wir das will
ich gerne einmal wegen Ihre Frage
ausführen jetzt richtig Tempo hinlegen
mein Deutschland ist
ein großes Industrieland wir verbrauchen
600 Terawattstunden Strom im Jahr das
ist ziemlich viel
und wenn wir jetzt das alles machen was
wir uns vorgenommen haben
elektrische Mobilität
elektrisches heizen mit Luftwärmepumpen
wenn wir
dafür sorgen dass industrielle Prozesse
elektrifiziert werden in der
Stahlindustrie in der Chemieindustrie in
der Zementindustrie das Wasserstoff
eingesetzt wird bedeutet es immer mehr
Strom also werden wir zum Ende des
Jahrzehnt etwa 57 Terawattstunden
verbrauchen und in den 30er Jahren
wahrscheinlich das Doppelte und das
bedeutet natürlich einen irren Ausbau
von erneuerbaren Energien oft schon
Windkraft Windkraft an Land Solarenergie
Ausbau des Stromnetzes das muss jetzt
alles mit einem gigantischen Tempo
vorangehen damit die Unternehmen und die
Privathaushalte sich nicht
verkalkulieren wenn sie darauf setzen
dass es genügend bezahlbaren Strom und
später Wasserstoff in rauer Menge gibt
das ist das was wir jetzt tun wir haben
auch die Förderbedingungen für
Privathaushalte verbessert was jetzt
Einspeisevergütungen ähnliche Regelung
bei Solaranlagen zum Beispiel betrifft
im Augenblick ist unser Hauptidee
allerdings dass wir auch helfen müssen
dass die Genehmigung schneller kommen
also daran arbeiten wir auch und da
werden wir ist immer so im
kurzen Abständen riesige Pakete vorlegen
wo wir lauter bürokratische Hemmnisse
beseitigen damit schneller geht und mit
diesen Vergütung versuchen wir natürlich
dann auch das wirtschaftlich zu machen
oder das Mieter das machen können und
ähnliches also das findet alles jeweils
etwas unterschiedlich abgestuft statt
hinbekommen müssen wir natürlich jetzt
dass die Leute die Rotoren für
Windenergieanlagen machen sagen ist
gerade nicht die beste Zeit für unser
Geschäft komisch aber ich produziere
jetzt trotzdem die zehnfache Menge und
investierende Milliarde oder zwei für
die Vergrößerung der Fabrik
weil ich glaube dass das alles passiert
und das ist eigentlich das was wo wir
dann da arbeiten und da helfen dann
manchmal solche Möglichkeiten aber auf
ihre Frage wir denken nicht nur an
halbleiterfabriken an Windrotoren und an
windkraftreder und Stromnetze und an
batteriefabriken sondern wir denken auch
an sie
dann würde ich hier noch mal Mikro
hinbetten zu der jungen Dame am Tisch
vielen lieben Dank Herr Scholz erstmal
beeindrucken wenn man sieht wie viele
unterschiedliche fragen Sie hier heute
abend beantworten inhaltlich kann man
sicherlich viel diskutieren mich
interessiert aber vor allem ihre Haltung
und ihre Politikstil vermeintlich wird
ihnen nachgesagt dass er ruhig eher auch
zurückgezogen zur agieren und wenn man
dann aber man die parallel ins Parlament
guckt in die Diskussion sieht man da ab
und zu doch starke Tendenzen von
Populismus populistische Tendenzen die
sicherlich nicht dazu führen dass wir
als Gesellschaft enger zusammenkommen
und deswegen werden meine erste Frage
was würden Sie als Bundeskanzler oder
auch als Politiker eigentlich empfehlen
wie wir da als Gesellschaft
entgegenwirken können also wir als
Gesellschaft sie aber auch als Politiker
und der zweite Frage habe ich als
Politiker und als Bundeskanzler sind sie
sicherlich daran interessiert auch
wieder gewählt zu werden wie gehen sie
eigentlich mit dem Zwiespalt um populäre
Entscheidungen zu treffen im Gegensatz
dazu vielleicht die richtige
Entscheidung zu treffen hier bezogen vor
allem zum Beispiel das Thema Klimaschutz
was daher neben mir auch schon erwähnte
beispielsweise Tempolimit oder ähnliches
also ich finde dass man zwei Dinge nicht
in einen Topf rühren darf nämlich
populär und Populismus also auch wenn
das das gleiche Wort ist sind das zwei
ganz unterschiedliche Dinge wer gewählt
werden will sollte schon irgendwie dafür
sorgen selbst mit seinem eigenwilligen
Kommunikationsstil dass er am Ende auch
die Stimmen kriegt nun ist mir das in
meinem Leben schon öfter gelungen ich
bin
zweimal als Regierungschef in Hamburg
gewählt worden mit ziemlich super
Ergebnissen ich habe meine Wahlkreise
für den Bundestag in Hamburg Altona an
den Potsdam immer direkt gewonnen und
ich habe es auch beim letztes Mal
geschafft ein großes Mandat der Bürgerin
Bürger für die Bildung der
Bundesregierung zu bekommen also
insofern habe ich mich irgendwie bemüht
dass die Leute am Ende finden da mache
ich das Kreuz
aber populistisch
ist ja eigentlich
wenn man
letztendlich mit den schlechten Gefühlen
arbeitet oder wie das wie man das sagen
können wenn man plötzlich in die
Vergangenheit verliebt ist eigentlich
hatten eine Gesellschaft ja nur eine
Perspektive es wird nur gut wenn wir
glauben die Zukunft wird besser wenn wir
die Chance sehen dass die Zukunft besser
wird wenn wir Wege finden wie man dahin
kommen kann und das ist exakt das was
ich was ich glaube was für uns wichtig
ist wie können wir die Zukunft gewinnen
und darum fange ich dann an auf die
Frage nach den privaten Windkraftanlagen
oder Solaranlagen zu antworten was wir
insgesamt machen müssen weil natürlich
mit der Entscheidung die deutsche
Automobilindustrie schafft es weltweit
verkaufbare erstklassige elektrofahrende
Autos zu produzieren auch die Hoffnung
verbunden ist dass wir das hinkriegen
Klimawandel zu schützen und gleichzeitig
Weltmarktführer in der
Automobilindustrie zu bleiben und das
könnte ich jetzt für viele andere Sachen
sagen also ein bisschen ist das auch für
die Zukunft wichtig und diejenigen die
sagen früher war alles besser was
meistens nicht stimmt und die sagen die
dann letztendlich sich gegen die
Verbesserung der Welt wenden indem sie
sagen lass uns rückwärts marschieren das
sind die Populisten von verschiedenen
Ecken und die führen immer dazu dass die
Welt nicht besser so ein schlechter wird
und dann finde ich darf man populär und
populistisch nicht verwechseln und auf
die Frage
was muss man tun natürlich muss man die
richtigen Entscheidungen treffen und man
sollte in der Demokratie das Vertrauen
haben und das hatte ich dass man
vielleicht nicht in einer Sekunde aber
doch über die Zeit für das was man
selber richtig findet an den Mehrheit
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger überzeugen
kann dieses Vertrauen gehört zur
Demokratie dazu dass man glaubt dass die
Demokratie funktioniert weil die
Menschen sich überzeugen lassen wenn ich
mit jemandem Rede selbst wenn er anders
guckt mache ich das immer mit der
Absicht es müsste doch gelingen dass
jemand am Ende sagt und sei es drei Tage
später
könnte richtig sein
dann haben wir noch eine Frage hier
hinten in der Reihe mit der Brille der
Herr in dem hellblauen Hemd genau sehen
das Mikro ist schon fast da
guten Abend Herr Bundeskanzler mein Name
ist Michael Grebe ich habe ein kleines
Bauunternehmen hier in der Region und
ich hätte gern von Ihnen mal beantwortet
wo die Reise bei uns in der
Bauwirtschaft hingeht warum weil die
Preise sind ziemlich in den
Rohstoffpreisen es war ziemlich bizarr
sage ich mal so in den letzten
6-7 Monaten jetzt gibt es keine
Förderung mehr für Neubauten die Preise
sind also historisch hoch Förderung gibt
es keine mehr ich weiß jetzt nicht wie
ein privater Bauherr
einverdiener oder vielleicht auch
anderthalb Verdiener wie die in Zukunft
ihr Haus bauen wollen oder wie die
Bundesregierung in Zukunft diese 200
oder diese irre Zahl 400.000 Wohnungen
pro Jahr stemmen will das hätte ich gern
mal beantwortet wo wie kriegen wir als
Bauwirtschaft eine Planungssicherheit
hin für die nächsten ein zwei Jahre ja
schon Dank
zunächst mal
wir haben Deutschland schon mal 800.000
Wohnungen gebaut in einem Jahr 1972
800.000
und die Idee dass das nicht geht dass
wir viele Wohnungen bauen wenn wir viele
Wohnungen brauchen die teile ich nicht
und das will ich sehr ausdrücklich sagen
da müssen wir wieder hinkommen und
deshalb ist die Zahl 400.000 Wohnungen
pro Jahr auch das Ziel dem wir
nachstreben weil das ja bedeutet dass
sich dann langfristig die Bauwirtschaft
also sie und ihre Kolleginnen und
Kollegen darauf einrichten können dass
wir das auch konstant verfolgen wollen
weil das bedeutet dass wir Kapazitäten
hochfahren müssen hochfahren müssen auch
was die verschiedenen Voraussetzungen
für ihre Tätigkeit betrifft es muss dann
ja auch mehr produziert werden was dann
im Bau verarbeitet werden kann natürlich
bedeutet das auch Fachkräfte die man
braucht in diesem Bereich und die
ausgebildet werden müssen und dort
eingesetzt werden sollen und darum ist
das auch ein Ziel von dem wir nicht
abrücken für mich heißt das so wir
müssen das Stück für Stück hinkommen
auch das wird jetzt gerade schwieriger
durch die gegenwärtige Preisexplosion
aber da darf man sich ja nicht von
abbringen lassen und wenn wir das
erreicht haben dürfen wir nie wieder
weniger Wohnung bauen als diese 400.000
pro Jahr
man kann das schaffen
als ich mich mal um ein anderes Amt
beworben hatte nämlich dass das
Hamburger Bürgermeisters hatte ich in
einer Zeit als alle behauptet hatten es
gibt kein Wohnungsmangel damit Wahlkampf
gemacht dass ich gesagt habe es gibt ihn
aber doch und die Bürger haben mir
geglaubt und ich habe gesagt wir wollen
6000 Wohnungen pro Jahr waren in der
Stadt danach sind es dann irgendwann
10.000 geworden und das ist bisher immer
erreicht worden so dass seit 2011 dort
glaube ich knapp 130.000 Baugenehmigung
erteilt worden sind eine ganze Menge und
eigentlich möchte ich dass wir das
deutschlandweit wiederholen eine solche
Mobilisierung unserer Kräfte
was die Fördermittel betrifft haben wir
die für den geförderten Wohnungsbau
massiv ausgeweitet da stehen jetzt 13
oder 14 Milliarden zur Verfügung
über die nächsten Jahre und die müssen
jetzt erstmal ausgegeben und eingesetzt
werden aber das heißt natürlich dass
jemand der vielleicht geplant hatten
Wohnungsbauprojekt mit Eigentumswohnung
für 10.000 Euro sogar Quadratmeter oder
mit Mietpreisen von 18 20 Euro
vielleicht umplant auf etwas was dann
für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger bezahlbar
ist und diese Mittel dafür in Anspruch
nimmt das wird jetzt ein bisschen
brauchen bis das passiert aber das ist
natürlich eine Zielsetzung die für uns
alle im großen Interesse ist ich weiß
nicht wie es hier in Marburg ist aber
ich kenne viele Städte wo ich mir das
mal angeguckt habe wenn man davon den
Beginn des geförderten Wohnungsbaus in
der Weimarer Republik also bei
1918/19 bis heute guckt kann man sagen
fast die Hälfte aller Wohnungen die da
stehen sind mal als geförderte Wohnung
gebaut worden selbst wenn sie längst
keine mehr sind und völlig normal
vermietet werden aber das prägt unsere
Städte und trägt dazu bei dass bewohnbar
sind waren und das es ein gutes Angebot
gibt insofern macht das Sinn und dann
haben wir in der Vergangenheit auch
nicht alles richtig gemacht also es gab
Fördermittel auch wenn jemand eine
ziemlich teure Wohnung für eine ganz
kleine Zielgruppe gebaut und verkauft
hat diese Wohnung sollen weiter
entstehen
jede Menge davon ich habe nichts dagegen
einzuwenden warum Fördermittel dafür
mobilisiert werden müssen muss man
allerdings fragen und dann haben wir aus
der Not eine Tugend gemacht und die ist
dann so ein bisschen verrutscht nämlich
dass wir die früher meistens
zinsförderung aufgegeben haben und
direkte Zuschüsse gemacht haben weil die
Zinsen so niedrig waren jetzt sind die
Zinsen aber wieder hoch und da haben wir
jetzt umgesteuert auf Zinsverbilligung
damit Familien sich die Kredite für den
Hausbau wenn das darum geht auch leisten
können und das machen wir natürlich
nicht für jede Einkommensgruppe aber
doch für ziemlich viele so und das ist
der Weg den wir jetzt gehen wollen da
werden wir uns dann lang arbeiten und
wenn das die Wohnungswirtschaft und der
Markt verstanden hat wie die
Förderbedingungen sind glaube ich wird
es auch funktionieren
es gibt da noch ein kleines Problem
nebenan wir brauchen den Neubau damit
die Wohnungsnot gelindert wird aber
natürlich müssen wir die bestandswohnung
auch besser machen insbesondere unter
klimagesichtspunkten
modernisieren und dafür haben wir ja
auch Programme die dazu beitragen dass
der riesige Bestand an Wohnung den wir
in Deutschland haben weniger Emissionen
verbraucht
Dankeschön jetzt haben wir nur noch fünf
Minuten schauen wir also eine Frage
kriegen wir auf jeden Fall noch unter je
nachdem wie knapp die Antwort aushält
vielleicht noch eine zweite hier vorne
die Dame mit der Brille am Stehtisch
da ist das Mikro bitte schön ja mein
Name ist Ute Badenhausen Klös ich bin
Sozialdemokratin wie sie
und
mir geht es um das Thema soziale
Gerechtigkeit
ich sehe
ein riesengroßen
eine riesengroße Differenz zwischen Arm
und Reich und das dazwischen das wird
immer weniger
da gibt es immer weniger Leute die in
diesen Bereich passen
und die die am Ende sind da sehe ich
halt eben auch die Problematik des
das
befördert die
stimmen die wir bei Wahlen am rechten
Rand finden und die wir alle nicht
unbedingt haben wollen
das ganze ist was möchten Sie wissen
verstärkt worden natürlich auch durch
die Krise
das ist verschieden das passiert aber
für mich ist der Punkt was kann Politik
da prinzipiell tun also nicht nur
Krisenfall helfen dass es nicht noch
schlimmer wird sondern
wo können wir das insgesamt wieder mehr
zusammenführen ja ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass das nicht eingetreten ist
was uns einige vorhergesagt haben der
wutherbst und der Wut Winter das liegt
ausschließlich daran dass wir eine sehr
stabile Volkswirtschaft haben
und daran dass wir einen doch im
internationalen Vergleich ganz guten
Sozialstaat haben und dieser
Zusammenhalt und die wirtschaftliche
Kraft haben es möglich gemacht dass wir
uns gemeinsam durch diese Krise bewegt
haben und es warm ist hier in der Halle
aber auch anderswo dass wir keine
gastkrise haben und so weiter
aber wir haben jetzt auch eine ganze
Reihe von Entscheidung getroffen die zum
Beispiel dazu beitragen dass diejenigen
die wenig verdienen besser zurechtkommen
das ist die größte
Einkommensverbesserung für Familien die
weniger als 2000 Euro brutto verdienen
in den letzten Jahrzehnten gewesen wir
haben für alle aber eben auch gerade
besonders wirksam für diese
Einkommensgruppe das Kindergeld erhöht
auf 250 € pro Kind davon profitieren
auch diejenigen die 3000 Euro verdienen
und 4000 und so weiter aber das wirkt
natürlich ganz stark wenn man nur 1500
Euro oder 1800 € verdient
und wir haben dafür gesorgt dass es für
Familien mit geringen Einkommen einen
höheren Kinderzuschlag gibt den gibt es
nämlich wenn man mit dem
Arbeitseinkommen und dem Kindergeld
zusammen nicht zurechtkommt und
eigentlich Grundsicherung beantragen
müsste Bürgergeld jetzt das ist dann
nicht mehr der Fall weil es diesen
Kinderzuschlag gibt auch 250 Euro dann
haben wir dafür gesorgt dass wir weniger
als 2000 Euro verdient ein geringeren
Beitrag zur Sozialversicherung zahlen
muss das heißt jemand der 1100 € brutto
verdient hat 50 € mehr im Monat das ist
schon eine ganze Menge gerade wenn man
so wenig verdient an Entlastung die
damit verbunden ist indem wir da sowas
gemacht haben wie im Steuertarif die
Beitragsbelastung der Arbeitnehmer
steigt erst allmählich und wir haben
dafür gesorgt dass wir eine geringe
Rente hat oder ein geringes Einkommen
jetzt das Wohngeld bekommen kann mehr
Leute kriegen das und es wird eine
höhere Leistung wir wollen also dafür
dass wir sich anstrengend aber leider
wenig verdient besser durchkommt und als
Basis haben wir auch noch letztes Jahr
den Mindestlohn erhöht auf 12 Euro
deshalb finde ich ist da so viel
passiert wie ganz ganz lange nicht
verstehe schon dass wenn alle über Krise
reden das so ein bisschen untergeht aber
ich finde das ist richtig auch wegen der
Gerechtigkeit im Land danke schön Herr
Bundeskanzler wir sind auch schon am
Ende die 90 Minuten sind rum
wir haben eine ganze Menge Fragen
beantworten können einige sind
sicherlich noch offen aber ich danke
allen die zugeschaltet haben für das
Interesse am 5 kanzlergespräch hier in
Marburg und natürlich allen
Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmern vielen
Dank dass Sie hier waren im
Bundeskanzler und einen schönen Abend
Ihnen auch einen wunderschönen Abend
alles Gute bleiben Sie gesund
[Applaus]
ja das war der Bürgerdialog des
Bundeskanzlers in Marburg ganz spannend
Bürgerinnen und Bürger konnten sich
dafür bewerben konnten sozusagen
antreten und Fragen stellen da Kanzler
wusste nicht vorher wer wann was fragt
der musste ständig von Thema zu Thema
wechseln selbst ja vielleicht
mitbekommen es war sozusagen keine keine
richtige themenordnung sondern es war
eigentlich jede Frage zu einem anderen
Thema und das hat die Sache schon
spannend für das Publikum gemacht damit
Sicherheit anstrengend für den
Bundeskanzler es war die fünfte
Veranstaltung dieser Art und der Kanzler
zieht damit durchs Land und will in
jedem Bundesland damit auftreten und in
die Nähe einfach von Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern kommen und hören was sie denken
was sie fühlen und auch wovor sie Angst
haben auch das war natürlich heute Thema
heute Abend in Marburg
möchte gerne darüber sprechen mit meinem
Politikwissenschaftler in Berlin von der
RWTH Aachen Emmanuel Richter herzlich
willkommen
guten Abend
das war schon ein themenhopping und wenn
ich mal ja dass das Abwege ich glaube
das Thema russischer Krieg gegen die
Ukraine war am stärksten angesprochen
und hat die Menschen am meisten
beschäftigt und es sind
Ängste geäußert worden bei denen der
Bundeskanzler gesagt hat diese Ängste
hätte man ihm im politischen Berlin so
bisher damit hätte man ihn gar nicht
konfrontiert oder man hätte nicht danach
gefragt was ich erstaunlich finde weil
wir beide z.B haben uns darüber durchaus
schon unterhalten wie fanden sie dass
der Kanzler mit dem Thema Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine umgegangen
ist
ja also ich habe denselben Eindruck wie
sie zunächst einmal das nehme ich dieses
Thema unglaublich präsent und dominant
war und man wundert sich weil man ja
eigentlich erwartet dass man zunächst
einmal so über die unmittelbaren Sorgen
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger in ihrem
Umfeld spricht und dass das zum Thema
wird aber das war eben kam ja auch zur
Sprache aber es war nur eines unter den
Themen und die Ukraine
Konfliktlage war eigentlich das
beherrschende Thema wenn man es mal
jetzt rein quantitativ betrachtet und ja
es tut natürlich glaube ich vielen
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern gut unseren
Bundeskanzler damals etwas
auskunftsfreudiger zu erleben und auch
etwas offenes zu erleben denn wenn man
ihn aus Interviews kennt dann merkt man
eben da ist er hier sehr Wortkarten
manchmal sehr sehr spröde man weiß auch
nicht so ganz genau was die Botschaft
ist und hier bei diesen Bürgerdialog war
das anders also da waren relativ klar
ausführlich und eben auch
auskunftsfreudiger offener und ich denke
dass ist eine ganz wichtige ganz
wichtiges Element denn diese
bürgerdialoge sind ja wenn man so will
Verfahren die so ein bisschen die
Schwächen der repräsentativen Demokratie
auffangen sollen ja das eben der Dialog
zwischen wählenden und
Vertretern Repräsentant und
Repräsentanten nicht eng genug
stattfindet und das wird ja an dieser
Stelle genau aufgelöst also insofern war
das eine gelungene Veranstaltung und ich
finde das sollte fortgesetzt werden es
wird ja auch fortgesetzt und das ist ein
Erfolgsmodell demokratischer
Kommunikation
noch mal ganz kurz bei dem Thema
Russlands Krieg gegen die Ukraine
bleiben da hat ein Bürger wörtlich davon
gesprochen dass er sich fürchtet vor
einer
Eskalationsspirale und dass er sich
fragt ob er noch Vertrauen haben kann
zum Kanzler weil so war sein Eindruck
schon mehrere Male Dinge erst den Abrede
gestellt wurden aber dann doch gemacht
wurden also zum Beispiel
Panzerlieferungen wie haben sie das
erlebt
ja das ist ja die Diskussion die wir
gerade in den letzten Tagen hatten mit
dem Stichwort Panzerlieferungen und dann
eben die unmittelbar anschließende Frage
die Ukraine möchte Kampf Flugzeuge und
der Kanzler sagt erst einmal das kommt
gar nicht in Frage und natürlich sofort
die Mutmaßung in den im Raum stand wie
lang wird sich dieses Versprechen halten
und halten lassen angesichts des
Kriegsgeschehens also insofern hat sich
Scholz da heute auch etwas vorsichtiger
ausgedrückt hat aber eigentlich gut
begründet weshalb er bei vielen
Schritten gezögert hat wie er eben immer
die Abstimmung mit den Partnern
insbesondere in der NATO sucht und wie
er versucht eben jegliche Eskalation die
zu einem Kriegseintritt Deutschlands
oder als Kriegseintritt Deutschlands
gewertet werden könnte wie er diese
Eskalation zu verhindern ist es
tatsächlich wirklich sinnvoll und
wichtig dass wir unseren Bundeskanzler
damals in dieser auskunftsfreude und in
dieser Ausführlichkeit erleben und ein
bisschen auch die Hintergründe der
Argumente die in der Bundesregierung
eine große Rolle spielen dass wir die
auch mal erfahren verstehen und
nachvollziehen können also ich glaube
das ist in diesem Fall besser gelungen
als je zuvor wenn man ein Beispiel noch
herausnehmen aus der Themenpalette würde
ich sagen die Gesundheitspolitik er
bezog sich da kurz auf eine Kranken
hausreform er bezog sich auf natürlich
die Pandemie die jetzt nach drei Jahren
ja wir glauben alle und hoffen es fast
zu Ende ist was hatten sie davon
Eindruck wie hat er das geschafft
zunächst einmal hat er ja glaube ich
Eindruck dadurch gewonnen dass es und
und geschunden sozusagen dass er eben
sich doch relativ gut auskannte also
sachlich hat er ja in vielen Gebieten
doch Detailwissen vorzuweisen und das
kam glaube ich gut an aber ich meine es
ist natürlich ein großes Dilemma im
Bereich der Versorgung von kranken auch
im Bereich der Bildung das hängt ja dann
zum Teil auch mit zusammen bis hin zu
migrationsproblemen wo eben die Frage
auftaucht wo kriegen wir Pflegekräfte
her also ich meine da kann er natürlich
auch nicht mehr als eben versuchen zu
begründen weshalb das eine noch nicht
klappt das andere aber geplant ist und
den Missstand der von den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern in Marburg beklagt worden
ist dass der eben noch ein bisschen Zeit
braucht bis er behoben werden kann also
insofern ist das für mich auch
interessant dass eben diese Frage
Gesundheitspolitik des große Themenfeld
Gesundheit das Politik doch so eine ganz
ganz bedeutsame Rolle spielt also die
Menschen haben da ganz offenkundig die
Wahrnehmung eines Mangels und das
Kommunizieren sie und die
Bundesregierung wird gut beraten sein
sich dieses Thema anzunehmen und ich
meine wir kennen natürlich Herrn
lauterbachspläne zu einer großen Reform
des Krankenhauswesens aber das muss
glaube ich noch mehr Stellenwert
erlangen in Hinblick auf die
innenpolitischen Themen bei uns in der
Bundesrepublik vielen Dank für diese
Einordnungen vielen Dank Professor
Emanuel Richter von der RWT Hachen in
Berlin
gerne